[Music]
love Anna what is you to Charles the
world is not the same as it was
mutants
they're gonna I heard myself today to
see if I still feel I focus on the pain
the only thing that's real mushy they
need this she's like you of time very
much like you the feelings disappear she
needs our help you are small come on
someone has come along I am still right
here and you
all
would find a way Logan
you still have time
[Music]
hey youtubers is Charlie so we finally
have the old man Logan trailer they're
just calling the movie Logan but it's
basically like old man Logan so I'll
kind of explain the comic book story but
that's not what they're doing it's gonna
be different from the comics so here we
go the Johnny Cash song makes it seem
like this classic Western like he's this
Clint Eastwood man with no name so
they're kind of going with that genre
are you to think of it as like Wolverine
The Last of Us or even like the Johnny
Cash is actually a fun Easter egg too
because James Mangold who directed this
movie he directed the last Wolverine
movie 2 also directed walked the line
the movie about the life of Johnny Cash
but the old man Logan story if you've
never read the old man Logan story it's
just as kind of the trailer presents it
the world becomes this post-apocalyptic
Mad Max fury road type of place the
actual story of that comic is actually
quite a bit different like the Hulk is a
big part of it he's a big villain so the
story of the movie looks like they kept
it relatively small like in the way the
Deadpool kind of exists by itself but is
also very connected to the x-men films
this is also kind of by itself to
literally set very far in the distant
future after mutants have potentially
died out so maybe in the way that like
the hope of the comics like Cyclops and
Jean Grey's daughter is kind of like the
hope of mutant kind after like the big
no more mutants arc in the comics
maybe this x-23 child is the same thing
because even though he's listed under a
different name
it looks like Richard II grant is
playing mr. sinister and basically wants
to use her to bring mutants back or do
something nefarious mr. sinister is a
terrible person so these people might be
working for him it did seem like in that
apocalypse post-credit scene like he was
trying to clone Wolverine
so that's who these cloths could belong
to there could be like a Wolverine clone
or these could belong to the little kid
I don't think they belong to the little
kid though these seem like they belong
to someone that's much bigger much more
powerful so unless it's like some saber
tooth twist there's probably some
Wolverine clone stuff happening in this
although you'd have to have Wolverine
clone anyway to get to X 23 but the way
he says that the mutants have all died
off but I'm curious with the
ramifications of this movie are because
the idea they're presenting is is that
this is
kind of like the end for Wolverine like
he's gonna give his life to save this
child and it looks like they're burying
Professor X at the end of this just to
give you an idea for how far in the
future this is after the current x-men
films I'm assuming it exists kind of in
continuity but is so far in the future
that everybody else has died off but you
have Professor X who's still alive who
might be like somewhere past a hundred
because you have to imagine during Days
of Future past Patrick Stewart's version
of Professor X is somewhere in his 70s
so I'm guessing that this is even
further past that looking at how old
that Logan looks I love the way he says
you still have time his body still
regenerates so he actually would still
have a number of years left but just
careful for spoilers for the end of the
old man Logan comic book story so I'm
gonna explain that I don't know that
they're doing that in this movie but
just to give you some context for what's
going on so at the end of the old man
Logan's story
he basically defeats this evil version
of Bruce Banner who's been twisted with
time like he literally eats Wolverine
and then Wolverine claws his way out of
his stomach because Wolverine
regenerates like he's very hard to kill
but then after that he vows to kill all
the evil in the land so even though it
seems like everything's gone to [ __ ]
it's sort of like this reawakening for
his character like I'm not gonna take
this [ __ ] anymore but it's like a hard-r
story so even though it doesn't look
like this movie has a rating yet I think
the intention is is to make this an
r-rated Wolverine movie and I am so here
for that
it's gonna be so awesome but I know
everybody's wondering that like what
about that little kid will the x-23
child pop claws and kill some people
during the movie let's just go super
hardcore because the whole idea of the
trailer is that this movie is mr.
sinister trying to use that childlike
trying to get his hands on her so he can
either bring mutant kind back or just
flat-out use every cell of DNA she has
for some terrible terrible purpose but
silly little kids she can't be dangerous
like she looks so cute there so you
remember what Wolverine was like when he
was a little kid like he actually killed
his foster parents kind of on accident
so I'm expected
her to wind up being just as deadly as
him at some point in the film but most
of the fun of it is just seeing them pal
around in the apocalypse trying to take
care of Professor X who looks like he's
in this hollowed-out version of cerebro
but it's actually the water tower like
it if it wasn't clear from the way they
edited the trailer they just want you to
be thinking about like the bones of
cerebro that he's inside here like it's
so old that everything is gone all their
friends are dead so I'm curious to see
if there's some sort of twist because
one of the reasons why I think they put
this so far in the future is is because
they didn't have to worry about
incorporating it into the main x-men
films if they didn't want to but there's
all kinds of ways to explain that just
you know don't expect them to address
this in the next x-men film but once we
get closer to that they'll probably
explain a little bit about what's going
on especially once they start doing
interviews for the movie but it looks
awesome
I can't wait to see Hugh Jackman go
crazy I can't believe that he's not
gonna be a Wolverine anymore even not in
like the Robert Downey jr. way where you
guest star a little bit in other
people's films but who knows what the
future of the character is you know one
they're either going to recast Wolverine
in a number of years like after they
feel like enough time has passed or two
they'll try to find some way around it
but you know I feel like they're not
gonna make like another Wolverine film
with this tiny little kid in another
year or so so like that's probably not
gonna happen
so let me know in the comments like what
do you think they're gonna do with the
Wolverine named after Hugh Jackman
formally passes on or they're just gonna
recast the character in a couple years
like for the next x-men film or do you
think they're gonna try and do x-23
stuff I feel like it's more likely that
they just wouldn't use the Wolverine
character for a little while but what's
gonna happen is a whole bunch more comic
book stuff happening with that Guardians
trailer yesterday so I'll do a follow-up
video for that in a couple days be sure
to subscribe to get everything
let me know if there's any Deadpool or
any bonus Wolverine videos you guys want
me to do
but next video is gonna be my arrow
video then we have just a society later
tonight on legends of tomorrow so
slightly new outro while you guys wait
for that next video
to post you can click up top for the
guardians of the galaxy trailer again
and you can click down here for all my
other Deadpool Wolverine x-men videos
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
there are two types of beings in the
universe